スニップなんていうのはすごい巧妙で
で 巧妙っていうのはこの発見すると逃げる
発見するよとすると逃げる
例えば「あんた怒ってるでしょ」と言ったと 「
いえ 違いますよ 怒ってない」と
すぐもうもう逃げるんですよ
その認めない そこで必死に心の中で怒ってないように演じようと
逃げをするんですよ で
見事に逃げたと思うんですよ
どういうことだと人に怒ってるけど
ただ失礼じゃないかと怒ってるんですよ
[笑い]いい加減なことをもう言うんなよと
そんな簡単に怒ると思ってるんですかと
言うても怒ってますけど
まあじゃあもううまく逃げたと自分が思ってるんです
そういう巧妙さがあります
それ巧妙と言いますかね
何 でも本人にとっては巧妙なんですよ
第三者から見ればバカで見ていられないんだけど
例えば本当にケチな物欲しがりの人に言ってみてください
ちらちらと あんたの性格ってね
まあちょっと私と比べてあんたはちょっとどちらかというとすごいケチでしょうねとかね
丁寧に言わないとね 丁寧に言うと
それからもう演じるは演じるはもう大盤振る舞いなんて言いますかね
いろいろやるんですよ
ケチでないということを見せるために
それから一人になったら
悔しくて悔しくて もう苦労するんです
そういう働きありますよ
心に これでみんな幸せやと思うんですけど
実はこれがややこしくて
あの核反応の連鎖 核 核
何て言いますか の連鎖反応みたいな感じで
ものすごい苦しいんですよ
例えばケチな人にちょっとまあどちらかというと我々性格を分析ちゃうね
私はあまり物を気にしない
あんたはちょっとケチでしょうねとかね
ちょっとこれはちょっと異常みたいな
すごいケチでしょうとか言うと
本人がまあそれがごまかそうと思ってまあ苦労するでしょ
だから本来ケチな人はいろいろ人にまあ奢ってあげたりする
しちゃうと精神的にはすごい苦しいんです
だから逃げ回ることで楽や幸せやと勘違いしてるだけで
ものすごく苦しいんです
それで我々の人生は心でできているんだから
心が人生だから 心が生きているんだから
物質ではなくて こういう性格ですーっと頑張ってるんです
ごまかしてやるぞと 演じてやるぞと
演じること自体苦しいことはないんですよ
だからあんたよく怒るなとか
あんたすごく怒ってるでしょと言った途端
我々はすぐ何か演じようとする
これですごく苦しくなる
何を演じるかっていうことを
またその人の心のレベルによって変わる
ある人はそうだよ 怒って何が悪いんでしょうか？と言うかもしれませんし
あるいはいいえ そんなことはとんでもない話ではないかと言って
ニコニコと笑ってくる笑う笑う顔の人もいるしね
いろいろですが それにも法則があります
で この演じるということはどんな心にもありまして
まあ演じるという単語の意味は調べた方がいいんですよ
演じることだから 本物ではないという意味なんです
ですから そこら辺ちょっとこの外国的な意味でとった方がいいんです
日本ではまあ演じるという
これこそ本物だという語でしょ
でも演じるんだから それはインチキよ嘘
本物じゃないんです 舞台で何かを演じるということは
その人はそのものじゃないんだからなんです
見事に悲しみを演じたというならば
その人は全然悲しくも何でもないんです
本当に悲しいんだったら演じる必要ないんだからね
芸術になりません 慰めてあげる
かわいそうやと思って
舞台ですごく悲しみを演じると
誰も慰めてあげようと思わない
拍手するんです 見事に良かったと
だから演じるということはそういうことなの
例えば ある俳優さんが本当に悲しい出来事があって
落ち込んで悲しくなっていると
誰も拍手しませんよ 慰めてあげる
頑張ってください しっかりしてください
ではなくて 舞台に上がって
もう悲しい場面をすごく演じる
それで客がもう悲しくて涙ポロポロ流しちゃったと
その場合は拍手します
演出家も 演じるっていうのはそういうことなんです
まるっきり逆でなきゃダメなんです
しょっちゅう泣き虫の俳優が舞台で泣いたって面白いことも何でもないんです
それで私たちはこのまるっきりないものを演じようと
私たちはというのは心が演じようとしているんです
これが苦しいんですよ
誰も拍手してくれないんです
だから客がない舞台っていうのは楽しくはないでしょ
見る人は一人もない 一人で演奏していると何のこともないんです
ですから 一人で自分がいろんなことを演じますけど
他人が騙してくれるでしょうと思ってね
騙されてくれるでしょうと
というか 何でしたっけ
でも そうはしてくれないんでしょうにね
騙されてくれたっても
本人が苦しいでしょうしね
それで理解してほしいのは
この巧妙さ 心の巧妙さっていうのは
心がね いつでも違いますし
違いますと自分の本質をあらわにしないようにするんです
なんでそんなことやるのかと聞いたっても分かりません
心さえも そこでお釈迦様はそのその原因を発見してあげるんですよ
そこで見事に矛盾を発見するんです
例えば 嫌なことだったらやらないのは理屈でしょ
一応やってみたところで嫌でした
だからやめますと そうすると矛盾がありません
心は何も知らん だから何かやったところですごく嫌になるでしょうね
でもやり続けちゃうんです
例えば 演じることが人生によって
演じることによって 人生が大変苦しいと分かっていても
演じることだけは絶対やめない
教えてあげてもやめないんですよ
あんたいい子ぶってるんだから大変でしょうと言ったら
そうですねと言ってまた行くんです
いくら言ってもこの性格を変えようとしないんですよ
そこは明らかに矛盾でしょ
法則的に言えば好きだからやっちゃったと言えばもうわかります
気持ちは嫌だからやめたと言えばね
生命の基本的なところで言えば
でもどこまででも演じて演じきるぞという
この絶対成功しない努力で頑張るんです
だから苦しみっていうのは生き物には付いているんです
この矛盾がある限り 逃げない
もうどうすることもできない
それで演じるということは
今私が言ったのは あんた怒ってるでしょとか言ったところでわかるやつでしょ
でもそれまた我々は見事に巧妙にやってるんですよ
なんでお化粧するんですかね
演じることでしょ 明らかに
何を演じてるんでしょう
私は格好悪い 年取ってるとかね
あまり魅力がない 他人が私にそんなに惹かれませんということを
事実を隠すために化粧するんですよ
明らかに演じてます それだけ気分いいんだよと言ったっても
そんなはずがないんですよ
演じること自体苦しいはずなんです
本来の気分で生きていられないんだから
素直に だからいくらプロ中のプロを頼んでお化粧してメイクアップしてもらって
かなりド派手に世界で振りもね
動き回っても苦しいはずなんです
だから気分がよくなればなるほど
裏で苦しみが溜まるんです
そんなのは俗世間が知ったもんじゃないんですよ
仏教以外は なんて幸せなお方でしょうかとかね
あの方にはもう専属のメイクアップアーティストいるんだよと
これまた一流の人であると
だから服装であろうが
アクセサリーであろうが
口ぶりの色であろうが
何でも洗練されて決まっていて
でもそれの裏にどれほど精神的な苦しみ隠れているのかと
それ法則だから違いますよと言っても
誰が信じるんですかね
といえば皆様信じますけど
仏教は信じませんよ 法則は変わりませんから
それでああいう豊かな人も突然自殺でもするでしょう
なんで麻薬使ったりするんですか？あれほど金持ちで神様扱いされていて
ちょっとサインということで
なんか落書きですけど
あれはね まあいつくしても何ともないんですけどね
色紙に落書き書くだけ
それすごい高いお金でまで売られるでしょうに
あれほど社会的な立場あって
なんで麻薬取ったりするんですかね
なぜ自殺するんですかね
日本でものすごい人気あるあの女
マリリン メアリーリン・モンロー
なんであんな死に方したんですかね
何か不満でもあったんですかね
普通考えるあれほどもう褒め称えても
どこに行ったっても すごい
でももうケネディさんの誕生日にって呼ばれたりするぐらいでしょうし
そちらでも気持ち悪い風な
あのものすごいその場に合わないことをやってもOKでしたからね
すごく下品でいろいろ身振り手振りやったりして
ハッピーバースデー歌ってますけど
ちょっともうケネディさんみたいなね
すごいレベルの人々の誕生日ではちょっと合わないんですよ
それでもみんなすごく喜ぶ
それぐらい自分の立場なんです
ああいうパーティーで彼女はスカートを上げて踊ったっても
誰も何も言いません それぐらいの立場があったのにね
だからどこで何があるんでしょうかというと
みんなぐちゃぐちゃいろんなくだらんことを言うだけで
その世間は 実際はこの巧妙なこの苦しみが溜まるんですよ
演じれば演じるほど そこは本人さえも気付かない
あまりにも忙しかったんだから
忙しかったら休めばいいでしょうし
すっごい立場があるんだから
1ヶ月とか休むそうと言っちゃえばな
みんなはいわかりましたと撮影停止するんだから
でもそんなものじゃないんですよ
やっぱり そこで音楽家だと世界に演じちゃったところでアイディアが出てこないでしょ
それちょっとちょっとアイデアあっただけで
そこで自分を騙しちゃって
音楽家で世界で食べてやるぞと思って
一応苦労してそれらの立場を取った途端
もう新しい音楽を作らなくちゃいけない
持っていたものは出して
なんとかうまく認めてくれたんで
それからどうするのかと
それから演じなくちゃあかんでしょうに
それで頭叩いて麻薬でも何でもやって
逆立ちでもしたり 崖から落ちたり
何でもして新しい音楽のアイデアを出そうとする
人生はもうめちゃめちゃになるんであって
幸福になるってことはないんですよ
だから心のこの演じる働きっていうのはもうすごい面白いんです
極端な苦しみを作っているんです
だったら辞めるのは当たり前ですけど
これが矛盾で辞めないんですよ
そういうこの永遠矛盾というものがついています
生命に 矛盾なことをやっていると
我々普段一人何と言いますかね
言ってることは矛盾だらけで
子供よく言うでしょうに
矛盾矛盾ばっかりで 皆様何言うかわかりませんだけど
私ならお前バカじゃないかと言ってる
違うでしょうと言うんですよ
日本で何言うかわかりませんだけど
一応矛盾なことばっかり言っちゃうとバカだと平気で言うんです
それは仏教の世界でもそこは無明で無知で
って言ってるんです 無明だと
これは無知というんだよと
愚か者やと だから愚か者というのは決して差別用語じゃないんです
それは心の特色を説明しています
先生 私が私がっていうエゴっていうのは無明の一つなんですか
うん [silence]